today on the matte wall show british
police are now carting people away in
handcuffs for the crime of causing trans
people to feel anxiety if you think this
madness isn't coming to the united
states you've got another thing coming
also ron desantis proves yet again why
he's the most effective republican
leader in the country he's got a couple
new moves that uh are really great we'll
talk about and a drag queen performed
for kids at a church in new york but the
story only gets worse from there somehow
in our daily cancellation the saga of
racist parade mascots continues we'll
talk about all that and more today on
the matt welsh show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the supreme court decision to overturn
roe is a huge albeit long overdue step
in the right direction but there's still
a long way to go to raid our country of
abortion completely many companies are
bowing to the woke mob by donating to
pro-choice causes and candidates or
reimbursing their employees travel
expenses so if they live and work in a
pro-life state they can travel to a
pro-abortion state and get an abortion
and then be back at work on monday well
what if i told you there's currently uh
you're currently on a phone plan with
one of the major care carriers if you
are you might be supporting these kind
of companies and their pro-abortion
agenda with your monthly phone bill you
might be inadvertently indirectly paying
for people to take vacations and get
abortions
don't let abortionists use your money to
fund policies you don't believe and
switch to charity mobile instead charity
mobile is a pro-life pro family cell
phone company that sends five percent of
your monthly plan price to the pro-life
charity of your choice you don't have to
compromise on values or good phone
service charity mobile offers the latest
5g phones no device or service contracts
great nationwide coverage and live
customer service space right here in the
usa the fight for the right to life
continues and pro-life causes need your
support you can help by simply switching
your phone service to charity mobile
today call 1-877-474-3662
or chat with them online at
charitymobile.com mention offer code
walsh to redeem a free cell phone offer
as well that's charitymobile.com and
mention code walsh
in many ways it would seem that western
europe along with canada and probably
australia are seated farther up on the
crazy train and you know that's probably
true but the important point is that
we're all on the same train headed over
the same precipice and down into the
same dark
depths uh to appear then over our
northern border or across the ocean it's
to look at our immediate future it's
like looking into a crystal ball
and that's why this story which hasn't
gotten very much attention in this
country ought to uh ought to get some
attention not to give us pause the daily
mail reported this week
they report an army veteran was arrested
by police for
causing anxiety after retweeting a
picture of a swastika made out of pride
flags on social media darren brady 51
has slammed hampshire police for
impeding his right to free speech after
he's placed in handcuffs on friday
at his home in aldershot for sharing a
meme footage of the arrest was widely
shared on social media and showed an
officer who told mr brady he was being
he was being apprehended because his
post had caused anxiety and been
reported to authorities the image mr
brady retweeted was of a swastika that
had been digitally manipulated and was
made out of four lgbt pride flags
well clearly the best way to disprove
the point he was making with the
swastika meme is to arrest him for
posting it
certainly not as it's not as though such
a response exactly demonstrates the very
thing the meme was commenting on
but i think you need to hear you heard
the reason there about anxiety but you
need to hear it for yourself the british
police officer
um explaining this as he's making the
arrest so here's the footage now watch
which police would
realize how ridiculous this is
ridiculous
because i don't understand
i posted something that he posted you
come to arrest me you don't arrest him
why has he come to this why am i in
cuffs because there's something
he shared then i showed because someone
has been caused obviously anxiety
based upon your
social media taste
someone has been caused anxiety by your
social media post you're in handcuffs
and will be carted to jail because your
meme
made somebody anxious
my favorite thing is the tone the
officer uses he says obviously someone
has been caused anxiety it's obvious of
course he's going to arrest you for
creating anxiety in the precious fragile
mind of some gender non-conforming
person obviously what else is he going
to do
what to the sane among us seems utterly
insane and totally beyond the bounds of
reason is to him
self-evident and uncontroversial
well this is no surprise coming from a
british british police officer after all
these are the people just recently a few
weeks ago caught on film in uniform
dancing at a gay pride rally let's see
that
[Music]
that's some uh real police work there i
suppose we have no room to laugh over
here in the states we've seen cops in
this country kneel at you know in
submission at blm rally so basically the
same sort of thing and we especially
cannot laugh because we are fast
approaching the day when
a meme critical of the trans agenda will
result in more than just a twitter
suspension
soon we're going to see people getting
carted away in handcuffs too and it will
happen it's going to happen and soon and
that move will begin
if biden has anything to say about it on
college campuses with this
administration's proposed changes to
title ix like we talked about when the
proposal was first published a little
while ago biden
wants to change title ix
not only to give men the unquestioned
right to access any female facility or
sports team anywhere they want without
impediment but also to make it a legal
violation as the british police officer
says to cause anxiety to a protected
class of people
there was a lawyer named cece o'leary
who recently explained the changes at a
heritage foundation event and she
explained that um
under the current title ix guidelines a
student or staff member at a university
could be considered in violation if they
engage in harassment
a verbal harassment
that is severe pervasive and objectively
offensive
that's the current rule as it is as it
stands now there are obviously problems
even with the rule as it stands
potential problems but it does create a
relatively high bar
okay if you want to get someone kicked
off campus for harassing you you have to
prove that what they're saying was
offensive
uh and and pervasive and severe all
three of those things
which means that you can't
hear something that somebody says that
offends you one time and then get the
person kicked out out of school
you have to prove that you were harassed
in a way that was severe and pervasive
and personal towards you
but as o'leary explains biden wants to
change the end
to an or
so it's not
severe and pervasive it's severe or
pervasive
and that will have absolutely
devastating effects for free speech on
campus obviously by design let's listen
to her explain it speech that would be
severe pervasive and objectively
offensive would be
a a man calling a woman a derogatory
name
he says it and we all agree that it's a
it's a bad name
he says it over and over again
and it causes her to maybe fear for her
physical safety maybe he's shouting it
at her as he's running after her that
would be harassment or maybe he's saying
it over and over and over again in class
to the point where she does not feel
safe going to class anymore that would
be harassment under the current rule
under the proposed change to the rule it
would just be saying a comment about um
it would be misgendering somebody it
would be saying
the wrong pronoun that that person does
not identify with under the new rule
that person could find that comment
severe
period and they could report you and the
college could find you uh guilty of
harassment
so under this new proposed change to
title ix we are worried that students
are going to have their speech chilled
even more than it already is students
are going to be deterred from ever
speaking up and saying anything because
they risk especially conservative
students will risk their views
being targeted and being punished now on
their campus so
you know a concrete example of this
could be you want to host a conservative
speaker let's say you want to have matt
walsh come onto campus and debate
somebody under these new changes to
title ix you might not be able to do
that because matt walsh could be labeled
a harassing figure and this is harassing
speech and therefore the college will
not allow him to come onto campus
so there are definitely some serious
concerns here with this title ix change
and i there are other concerns as well
that i'm sure my co-panelists can speak
to
well of course you want to keep that
unsafe character off your campus but
generally
the groundwork is already laid here the
foundation has long since been excavated
now all the tyrants have to do is start
building on the work they've already
done
to say something that somebody in a
privileged class doesn't like to make
them uncomfortable whether intentionally
or not
is to commit harassment
and harassment is a violation on college
campuses harassment is a crime actually
criminals get arrested so you see how
the dots connect it's not very hard to
see but in fact the foundations for this
kind of words are violence idea
foundation goes further back and is
deeper than most people realize
if you have heeded my many
recommendations to read carl truman's
book the rise and triumph of the modern
self then you'll know that
this is all the consequence
of um what other philosophers have done
dubbed living in the age of the
psychological man or the expressive
individual
now for most of human history as truman
talks about in this book human beings
found meaning and purpose through
external
realities um happiness and fulfillment
could be found in the ways that we are
situated within stable structures like
the family the community the church
your country right individuals define
themselves by these relationships and
these roles if you had gone to a person
you know at any point before modern
times and asked them to tell you about
themselves they would have immediately
started talking about
the roles that they that they play they
would have identified that well i'm a
father i do this for a living that's how
they would have um identified themselves
they probably would have
listing their faith probably first and
foremost
but that's all changed in the modern age
now individuals are encouraged to find
meaning inside themselves as truman
wrote in an essay on this subject a
couple years ago
it is the this is the notion that human
flourishing is found primarily in an
inner sense of well-being that
authenticity is found by being able to
act outwardly as one feels inwardly and
that who we are is largely a matter of
personal choice not external imposition
and of course i would add that the
rejection of external imposition
includes
biology
and nature
because we're now meant to believe that
even nature even god cannot impose on us
any definition of our true selves
nobody decides who or what we are nobody
in nothing it's totally up to us this is
entirely determined by our own egos and
our ego is where we live
we are absorbed within it barely coming
up for air
this shift in the way that human beings
see themselves
this transformation or degradation
as the case may be in the very
definition of selfhood
is what explains nearly everything that
we're seeing happen around us
and it's what has led
and will continue to lead to the
forcible suppression of many kinds of
speech
especially speech that causes someone to
question their inner experience of their
own selfhood right speech that causes as
the police officer said anxiety
since your inner self is all that
matters since it's the truest version of
yourself then speech which interferes
with it becomes a form of violence it's
it's murder in effect
and that's why the enemies of free
speech can stamp out free speech
wherever they find it while claiming
and actually believing that they cherish
free speech they could be on this
crusade to utterly destroy free speech
while telling themselves and everybody
else
and and being dude enough to actually
believe that that they cherish the very
thing that they're destroying
because in their minds what they're
attacking is in speech you know it's
violence it's assault
it's murder
maybe not physically
but internally
and as we've seen the internal
is all that matters
and that's what's happening now let's
get to our five headlines
[Music]
it's been a big year for healthcare data
breaches a recent breach at a debt
collection firm exposed data from 1.9
million patients tied to 657 healthcare
providers that's a huge number of people
affected but as crazy as it sounds
that's the that's only the third largest
health care breach reported this year
the other two impacted 2.8 million
people and 2 million patients
respectively it's important to
understand how cyber crime and identity
theft are affecting our lives every day
your personal information gets exposed
so often that it's dangerously easy for
a cyber criminal to steal your identity
protecting your identity then can be
easy with lifelock by norton lifelock
detects and alerts you to potential
identity threats that you may not be
able to spot on your own like if loans
are taken out in your name things like
that if you do become a victim of
identity theft a dedicated us-based
restoration specialist will work with
you to fix the problem
nobody can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions at all
businesses but it's easy to help protect
yourself with lifelock identity theft
protection starts right here join now
and save up to 25 off your first year at
lightflock.com walsh that's lifelock.com
walsh for 25 off
all right i have to tell you about this
because it's been weighing on my mind
before we get to the five headlines if
you'll bear with me i just i've been
struggling with it and i've been
i've hesitated to talk about it because
i don't want to
throw my employer under the bus but i
have to get this off my chest
come on may
so this is something that i just found
out about recently when my producer sean
told me about it
apparently
back when johnny the walrus first came
out
somebody here at the daily wire got the
idea that they should celebrate the book
and congratulate me for the success of
my book which you can still buy at
johnnythewalrus.com
by having a custom
stuffed walrus made and then they would
give it to me
and they wanted the stuffed walrus to be
like as big as a real walrus like this
this massive thing at least the size of
a large beanbag chair and this plan was
agreed upon and they decided they were
going to surprise me with the stuffed
wallburst because because everyone knows
i love surprises
and they're going to give it to me
during a backstage episode so they had
this huge stuff walrus made custom made
who knows how much it cost it and uh
they had it shipped to the office they
carted it in it was like a surprise
unbeknownst to me i didn't know about
any of this everything was in order
everything was paid for and received and
then they just
they just never gave me the walrus
for whatever reason the the enormous
stuffed walrus was never actually
given to me the whole plan was executed
every part of it except for the part
where i was actually given the gift
and so that's why now today there is in
our office like in storage somewhere
this huge stuffed walrus that no one
knows what to do with it's just sitting
there
and what makes this so bizarre again is
not that they decided to bail on the
plan of giving me a huge stuffed walrus
that would be understandable it's that
they it's that they they made it and had
it shipped and then never never gave it
to me
uh so sean told me about this and and of
course my question was
well can i have it can i can i have my
walrus
and he said do you want it i said yeah
of course i want it what do you mean
it's my walrus it was made for me i want
the big stuffed walrus and it was still
never given to me and then yesterday
where i'm in my office with mckenna and
sean i bring it up again i said can i
can i have my stuff walrus i would like
to have it
and they again the question was well do
you really want it
yes i want the walrus and so yesterday i
go looking for the walrus i can't find
it anywhere and now i'm starting to
think did they re-gift it
was this giant stuffed walrus given to
somebody else
so it's a really it's an awkward
situation where this gift was never
given to me and now i'm asking for it
and they still won't give it to me it's
really bizarre
why can't i have my walrus is my
question
this walrus it's like the equivalent of
it's the it's the walrus equivalent of
the bridge to nowhere it's like a this
bureaucratic boondoggle
this random expensive thing that was
that was never used for anything and i
just don't know what to do so
that's it
give matt his walrus
um
we will go here maybe something slightly
more important than the saga of the
stuffed walrus
is this and uh this was
kind of teased yesterday that from
rhonda santa's camp down in florida that
they were gonna be making a big
announcement and then they made it today
and this is from uh actually there are a
couple of big announcements we'll go
with uh what happened today
this is fox news it says republican
florida governor ron desantis suspended
liberal state attorney andrew warren on
thursday desantis made the announcement
during a thursday press conference uh
broadcast on social media desantis
argued that warren has repeatedly
refused to enforce laws
passed by the legislature cracking down
on child sex change surgeries and
abortion restrictions desantis office
said in a statement we are suspending
soros-backed 13th circuit state attorney
andrew warren for neglecting his duties
as he pledges not to uphold the laws of
the state the constitution of florida
has this is desantis now quoting the
constitution of florida has vested the
veto power in the governor not in the
state attorneys we are not going to
allow this pathogen of ignoring the law
to get a foothold in the state of
florida
officials said warren has repeatedly
tried to install himself as an
adjudicator of what laws will and will
not be allowed
and uh and so now they're saying that
they're going to simply suspend him now
this is this is a big announcement a big
and significant announcement
um it shouldn't be
right i mean that this shouldn't even be
news
at all it we should see this and say oh
well right so again
a republican governor is suspending a
d.a who refuses to enforce the law
because this is the kind of thing we
should have seen many examples of this
already
because there are
a great many
um
district attorneys all throughout the
country who have just decided
of on their own that no i don't like
that law so i'm gonna pretend it doesn't
exist i'm gonna rewrite the law for
myself
and determine which laws will be
enforced and which won't be enforced
and these da's have made this and and
again most of them yes funded and
installed by george soros and they've
made this decision and oftentimes
they're in blue states where there's no
one who could even hold them accountable
who has a position of power but then
oftentimes also they're in red states
and the red state governors just sit
there
um sitting on their hands like they
can't do anything about it they're
totally powerless
what desantis is doing here is of course
exactly the right thing to do
if you're not going to do your job then
you're done
you don't get to decide what laws are
enforced i don't care if you don't like
the law
okay as a district attorney in a city
the city is not your own little fiefdom
where you can make up the rules for
yourself if you don't like the rules if
you don't like the laws and don't want
to enforce them then step down and let
someone else step in who will do his job
this is your duty this is your
responsibility
but what makes this
sort of significant
and even somewhat
shocking in a way
is again that
republicans never do this kind of thing
this is um
one of the most consistent things about
republicans is that of course they're
usually useless
and they do not want to use the power
that they've been given
that that goes to republicans who are
governors of states that goes to
republicans
on the federal level in congress
and that also applies to many republican
presidents that we've had including the
most recent republican president
who was very reluctant to use the power
that had been
given to him
by the nature of his office
uh and you could kind of see why
republicans would be afraid and don't
want to use the power that they're given
a couple of reasons one is that if you
use the power that you've been given
that you're putting yourself in line for
lots of criticism from the left and from
the media and uh the piranhas are going
to swarm around you and try to eat you
alive right so they're trying to avoid
that because they're cowards
but then the other thing too is that
you know when you have power and you use
it
now you're putting yourself
you're going out on a limb
um
because if things don't if things go
wrong if things go badly now you could
be held accountable for that
so it's a lot safer to be given power
and then
never use it
just kind of coast along
enjoying the prestige of your office
enjoying all the different perks that
come with it but never actually using
your power because if you never do
anything then no one can
criticize you for the things you did
because you didn't do anything
i think the real courage that we see
with desantis i mean even aside from
facing down the radical left and
everything else the real courage is
being being willing to do things
to do what he's supposed to do
um in his position
and
and and live with the consequences if it
doesn't go right then then that's on him
and he knows that he's willing to do
that to to uh
accept that
i mean this is just
i know you've heard me say it so many
times but
it's such an obvious choice and he
hasn't announced yet his his run for
president 2024 but
um
i think he will announce
i think he's all the more likely to
announce if the people you know if
especially
republican and conservative voters speak
up and say we want you to run please run
you're the guy
i think he'll definitely run in that
case
i think the only thing that would stop
desantis from running is if he looks at
the situation and decides
that there's a lot more enthusiasm among
republicans for trump
and so he doesn't want to get in there
and get into a nasty battle with trump
so he's going to sit it out
and so i think it's really important for
all of us those who have platforms and
we all have platforms these days no
matter how big or small your platform is
if you're a republican if you're a
conservative to say no he's the guy
please run i think you're the guy
there's just
there are some other republicans out
there that could that that i hope also
run because i you know i don't want an
uncontested primary right you wanna and
it's uh iron sharpens iron and that kind
of thing and there are some other
interesting options but
when you have someone who's a young guy
governed successfully isn't afraid of
the left isn't afraid to use the power
that he's been given all ever checks
every single box so
it's could not be more obvious
and speaking of checking the boxes that
was yesterday now let's go back to or
rather this was this morning let's go
back to yesterday when ron desantis
announced that there's going to be
accountability in his state now for
doctors who mutilate children listen
talk about these very young kids getting
gender affirming care they don't tell
you what that is is they're actually
giving very young girls double
mastectomies they want to castrate these
young boys that's wrong and so we've
stood up and said both from the health
and children well-being perspective you
know you don't disfigure
10 12 13 year old kids
based on gender dysphoria 80 of it
resolves anyways by the time they get
older so why would you be doing this i
think these doctors need to get sued for
what's happening i'm sorry
uh they need to be
sued
yes absolutely and we are going to see
uh the lawsuits that are going to be the
class action lawsuits that we're going
to see
certainly in the next 10 years
as all these children children who are
being drugged and castrated and
mutilated as they uh get older and
become adults and experience
unimaginable
regret
and i almost hesitate i i don't even
like the word regret here because regret
is when you
uh are are
feeling sorry about something that you
did right that's that's what regret is
when you're feeling some kind of guilt
or second-guessing something that you
have done a choice that you have made
but with these children
who are being drugged and castrated
everything else this is not a choice
that they're making because they can't
make these kinds of choices this is
something that's being done to them
so call it whatever you want it but as
they get in the next 10 years as this
current um
crop of children and crop is certainly
how they're seen by the uh
pharmaceutical industry and by all these
doctors that are taking advantage of
them and profiting off of uh
off of
abusing them
as they get older become adults
we're going to see massive class action
lawsuits
as well we should but the really tragic
thing is that on top of class action
lawsuits we're going to see
uh
a wave of mass suicide unlike anything
that the world has ever seen
and we're already seeing suicide rates
that are far above historical average
historical norms especially for younger
people
but i'm telling you right now in the
next 10 to 15 years what we're going to
see is j it's unthinkable
because you're gonna have millions of
what we're once kids coming into
adulthood
and looking and realizing that
their lives have been destroyed their
bodies have been destroyed they've had
things taken from them and they can
never ever get back
and it's just it's impossible to even
conceptualize
the anguish and pain that someone must
feel in that situation and what happens
from there is going to be
utterly tragic and brutal
which is why we should be doing
everything we can right now pulling
every lever that we can
um calling on every republican with any
power at all
but do we do to be doing everything they
can to put a stop to this and to punish
to the full extent possible under the
law everyone responsible for it
that to me should be
you want to talk about 2024 any election
really primaries
uh
any
election this should be one of our first
questions for any republican
it's like first of all how do you feel
about
children
getting gender reassignment care
quote unquote
and if they say anything other to that
other than it's horrifying and evil and
terrible anything less than that we
can't even consider them
but then the next question is what do
you what do you want to do about it
the doctors who are responsible for this
if it was in your power to do it would
you put them in prison
are you in favor of passing laws that
allows us to take these doctors and put
them in prison
any answer from a republican other than
hell yes
let's imprison these bastards uh then
that person can't be considered for any
elected position at all
speaking of uh puberty blockers the
daily wire i've had this on the docket
here for a few days daily wire had this
report i think this was last week
it says puberty blockers known as
ganadropin releasing hormones
receive it received a warning from the
u.s food and drug administration
officials earlier this month saying the
drug could cause brain swelling
loss of vision and serious risks for
children injecting the hormone officials
said a plausible association between
using puberty blocker
and puberty blockers and other symptoms
which display there's there's one
disease in particular that i can it's
pseudotumor
cerebri i think which displays symptoms
similar to a brain tumor this was either
so they said there's an association
potentially between that and the puberty
blockers and this has been identified in
six young girls between the ages of five
and 12.
fda officials reported five were
undergoing treatment for
central precocious puberty and one for
transgender care
the onset of this disease ranged from
three to 240 days after uh the
initiation of the puberty blockers
this is the other thing that we're going
to see
in the coming years
is um
the fda and other
public health agencies are going to come
out with reports saying oh well you know
it turns out that
maybe these drugs do have some side
effects
and
because we can't even you
we can't begin to list all of the
potential side effects from drugs like
this
because we've never had
you know an entire generation put on
these drugs we haven't had the sample
size now we do
and we're going to find out as the years
go on
all right
press from business insider says
president joe biden on wednesday signed
his second executive order aimed at
protecting abortion access since the
supreme court overturned roe v wade in
late june biden's executive order
instructs the human and health services
department to support patients who will
travel out of state to get an abortion
where it's still legal this is according
to a white house fact sheet
biden explains this executive order
let's listen to him explain it
no today i'm signing the second
executive order i'm about to sign
that response to the health care crisis
that has unfolded since the supreme
court overturned roe
and that women are facing all across
america
health care crisis is
you know
it's just it's hard for me to even
understand how they think this health
care crisis is women can't get can't
choose
can't get an abortion even in the case
of incest
even in the case of rape
but it goes beyond that
there are a lot of women who take
prescriptions prescribed by their
doctors and taking for some time for
other conditions
for arthritis or epilepsy for crohn's
diseases
and in many cases these prescriptions
are not being filled
uh well that's just that of course is a
total lie there's nothing about the
overturn of roe v wade that would
prevent
women from taking medication for
arthritis
this is an advantage of course being a
democrat you just you could utterly
totally invent things out of thin air
and you're not going to be fact checked
on that especially when it's something
if it's if it's in the realm of abortion
then they're not going to fact check it
you can as far as they're concerned ends
justify the means and
just say whatever you need to say
to bring about the end that you want and
the end that you want of course is the
murder of more babies which is
healthcare
but like we talked about with euthanasia
yesterday that that can never be
healthcare
this could never be medicine
if you have a doctor who is
intentionally destroying human life
then that is always and forever going to
be the opposite of medicine
you can call it whatever else you want
but you cannot call it medicine you
can't call it healthcare and what you
should be calling it obviously is murder
here's a
a
video that's kind of been making the
rounds online for the last couple of
days and it's actually from i think one
or two years ago
but still somewhat instructive
alexandria ocasio-cortez
appeared on
one of these drag queen shows maybe this
is rupaul's show i don't know she
appeared with some drag queens to uh
give them a little pep talk
and let's listen to her
people who change what people think are
artists and drag queens and let's not
forget who threw that first break at
stonewall
you know that is what led to us
passing the equality act and the house
in this term
marriage equality it starts with you i
mean your patriots
you are
you are you are patriots and i'm so
proud of you all i'm so proud to live in
this country with you and with your
mother
and
with all of us as family
there we go there was her patriotic
speech her uh war cry that was her
general patton
moment to the drag queens
the fact that she calls them patriots
is significant we heard something
similar from nancy pelosi who also
appeared on one of these drag shows and
said almost exactly the same kind of
thing about how this is you know you she
makes the drag queens men dress like
women
um make her proud to be an american and
this is the most american thing and it's
patriotic uh it
why is it why is it patriotic how could
it be patriotic for men to dress up like
women
well they're not dressing like women
because that's
i think we have to be careful when we
say that because i've never ever seen in
my life a woman who dresses anything
like a drag queen now they're dressing
like a cartoon a mockery of a woman
they're not gonna be patriotic well the
answer is
uh relating back to something we talked
about a few days ago
that
remember on the left
the only right that they care about
the only right that they recognize
the only right that exists in their
minds is the right to sexual
satisfaction
sexual gratification
you know that is so you are
a champion if you're a champion of
sexual satisfaction
then you are a champion of human rights
which makes you
now being a country as america is
founded on the notion of human rights
then then you're a patriot
which of course it's true if you
actually are a champion of of actual
human rights then you're a patriot yes
the problem is that this human right
doesn't really exist
it is another invention of the left
but that's the way they see it it's the
only right it's actually the only right
that anybody has
is just to satisfy yourself sexually
and it's why they believe that uh you
know they could take away every other
right which they don't even recognize as
existing but they get the right to
the right to free speech the right to
self-defense certainly the right to uh
freedom of religion
everything else
the due process they take all that away
because as long as they leave for you
the ability to satisfy your sexual whims
then that's all you should want because
that's all that's all it means to be a
person as far as they're concerned
that's why drag queens are patriots
because
for the drag queen
the cross
um traipsing around in women's clothes
this is their fetish they're acting out
their fetishes in public
which is a deeply patriotic thing to do
in aoc's warped vision of the world but
the drag movement has we know that it's
made its way certainly
outside of hollywood and it's made its
way into libraries and schools and now
it's made its way even into
churches so here's another some more
viral footage making the rounds a drag
queen
recently appeared at well
this is a church we'll play this for you
this is an event called worship is a
drag
and the drag queen here who comes out
claimed that this was at a catholic
church but if you've ever been in a
catholic church and you see this footage
you could tell this is not a catholic
church it is a church though supposedly
and um anyway let's watch the footage
first
her name is britta filter and she is the
queen of new york
[Music]
[Applause]
ah
[Applause]
okay so there's the drag queen marching
down the aisle of the church to the uh
the sounds of these screaming throngs
applauding the drag queen's name is
britta filter
okay
and but you see that there are a few
things about it that are a little bit
confusing right
and the first thing well many things
when you see a drag queen at a church
unfortunately that that actually is not
the most
sadly these days seeing the drag queen
at a church is is actually not confusing
at all that's quite expected i'm not i'm
not even surprised now to see that
the thing that did surprise me when i
saw this footage
was not the drag queen
but it was the the number of people
in attendance and how young they are
the fact that it's a whole bunch of
young
people because what i know is that
generally these far left churches
that are trying to attract the young by
you know bringing drag queens in and hey
let's have a transgender lesbian bishop
and all that kind of stuff preaching
from the pulpit constantly about
tolerance and acceptance and really
preaching about this right to sexual
satisfaction which is the only human
right that they recognize either
those kinds of churches though they are
doing all this ostensibly to attract
young people
um
they they fail to do so but if you if
you see footage usually like this and
you look out and you see who's in the
pews it's it's geriatric it's like it's
you're looking at something from the
from the from the local nursing home
there's a there's a smattering of
older middle-aged to elderly people in
the pews and it's just because this is a
dying old church
and this method
of trying to energize the young actually
doesn't work
it's not hard to see why it wouldn't
work
because for young people first of all
young people are
inherently
attracted to authenticity
and they
and they can tell when someone's being
inauthentic
like if you're being a poser
and you're putting on a show
they can kind of sniff that out
so the stereotypical like youth pastor
who's 45 got the backwards hat trying to
use young lingo but he's always about 10
years behind the times
yeah he's just usually what he gets is a
bunch of you know
rolling eyes from the kids that he's
talking to
and also kids know that
okay well if i want drag queens and if i
want transgenderism
and if i want all this preaching about
tolerance and diversity i can go
anywhere else in the culture for that
and i can get a much more authentic
version of it i don't need to go to a
church for that why why would i go and
waste my time they figure sitting in a
church to hear about drag queens and
trans and everything else like i go i
turn on the tv i can go anywhere i can
go anywhere and get that
um
the churches have made themselves
irrelevant by offering something
that
isn't needed in our culture because it's
already supplied everywhere else
yet you watch that and you and i it
almost it almost threw me for a loop i
said well there are a lot of young
people there
well here's why there were so many young
people there this is from the
post-millennial it says students at
manhattan's grace church high school are
required to attend chapel every other
wednesday on april 27th that meant
attending a pride event
the sixth annual pride chapel featured a
special guest drag queen brita filter
aka jessie avaya
students felt pressure to join in to
dance and celebrate while teacher euan
guin took the opportunity to announce
their resignation over improper pronoun
usage
there was tons of social pressure to
dance along and pretend like it was
normal according to a student who asked
not to be named
but said this to the post-millennial
whether it be people tapping on
shoulders and telling them to stand up
or just a collective staring contest
that whoever wasn't totally
participating
the event was led by the school also the
reverend and the students and faculty
advisors for spectrum which is the
school's lgbtqia plus affinity group the
politically themed chapel which was
mandatory for all students in grades
9-12 apparently ran long
according to multiple students
immediately upon entering there was a
person handing out stickers with pride
flags on them
unironically saying take one or you're
homophobic
and then eventually this teacher got up
there and resigned because the pronouns
weren't being respected that's how the
story ends
okay so that explains
my assumption was is not wrong my
assumption that chur the uber liberal
far left church is
trying to attract young people only
exceed attracting people 50 in the in
the 50 plus age bracket uh that that
still stands
those kids were there because they were
required to be there mandatory
attendance
to watch the drag queen the
obese man in a dress calling himself
brita filter
dance down the aisles
and not only that but required to
stand applaud
i mean
very much like what you see footage out
of north korea
when kim jong-un is parading before
the cheering throngs and everybody is
they're standing up and they're
and they're screaming and they're crying
tears of joy they love dear leader so
much but what you don't see is just off
camera the guys with the guns pointed
right out the screaming throngs saying
you better keep clapping or we're gonna
pull the trigger
very similar situation here
all right finally before we go to the
comment section the white house tweeted
this yesterday
and um it's not so much the caption but
the picture that
is significant here but this is
president biden tweeted this morning i
held a secure phone call with my
national security team we discussed a
wide range of priorities including the
united states support of free and open
indo-pacific and our continued support
for ukraine in response to putin's war
who cares about that what i do care
about is the picture and it's joe biden
on the phone
with a mask he's wearing a mask while
talking on the phone
i guess this is responsible he wants to
make sure that he doesn't transmit
covid over the phone now or and he also
wants to make sure he doesn't contract
it again
now he is very susceptible to covet
right he's he's he's had covered 47
times so maybe this extra precaution
could be somewhat understandable but
and i and i see that and i'm tempted to
make fun of it but then i realize you
know what i'm actually fine with this
yeah let's i'll go with that you can get
cove it over the phone i'll believe it
i'm willing to believe that in fact i
want to believe that because that gives
me an excuse to never answer the phone
again and never return any phone call
it's just too much risk
of course i never return phone calls
anyway but now i have an excuse it's
because i don't want to get covered now
let's get to our comment section
[Music]
h mill says we did everything backwards
we got married young 19 and 22 and my
husband worked on his degree over the
years debt-free at his job
uh either paid for it or he saved enough
he graduated with his master's degree
after our fifth child in his 30s we now
have zero debt live off his income alone
and he's in a job he loves and we have
six children that we homeschool i'm glad
we did things this way instead of the
way we had been told
um i think that's right that's not
backwards at all actually the way the
way that you did it is um
maybe backwards by modern standards but
the modern standard is what's backwards
it's exactly backwards uh live your
young adult life
um establish yourself do all that and
then at the end of young adulthood
start a family now that's backwards
ideally it doesn't work this way for
everyone not everyone's the same but
ideally the path for most people and
what we should be encouraging as a
society is that people begin the family
life at the beginning of young adulthood
not at the end of it
um
alice says matt i love following your
wife on twitter she seems so innocent
and joyful the opposite of you
uh she is that's true
one of the many things i love about her
she is she is joyful she is also
innocent i want to know how innocent
so here's another true story this is
almost as mind-boggling as the giant
stuffed walrus that i have not been
given though though that is rightfully
mine
so i was talking my wife yesterday and
uh i mentioned something about um
about reddit
actually it's because it's because uh
our pregnancy announcement ended up on
the
anti-natalist
reddit forum and anti-natalists of
course are the people who are against
babies this is this is even a level
beyond pro-abortion they just they're
against birth they don't think that
anyone should be born ever again because
human life is a misery and a drudgery
and we should all just perish from the
face of the earth anyway the the
pregnancy announcement ended up on the
reddit forum and there's just a whole
bunch of people very very upset that my
wife and i are having more kids i
thought was pretty funny i mentioned it
to my wife
and her answer was um
what's reddit
and i looked at her in shock and i was i
said
you don't know what reddit is how old
are you
you've never heard of reddit
and so i had to explain reddit to her
and this is what she said i quote this
is exactly what she said she said
oh so it's like an aol chat room
and i said that that's your frame of
reference in aol chat room what is this
1997
this is exactly like if i if i mentioned
google and she said what's google and i
explained it and she said oh so it's
like the dewey decimal system
but
this is good it's very you know it's it
i think it's a it's it centers me in a
certain way
to be married to someone who is not only
exactly opposite of me personality wise
and being bubbly and chipper and
everything but um is so not online that
she has never even heard of reddit
somehow i don't know how you do it i
mean how do you spend
how do you live in the internet age as
someone in your 30s just you've gone
your whole life and never encountered
any mention of reddit it's amazing
but it's great uh brittany says matt i'm
a mom of four and proud minivan owner i
lost my coolness points three kids ago i
only i only care for comfort these days
the extra 30 seconds it takes for the
for the sound of screaming children to
travel from the back of the van to the
front was worth the purchase alone it's
the most luxurious way to travel give
her time and she'll grow to love it
well that's my view you know um you have
to give up coolness give up style when
you become a parent of course it was
easy for me to do because and i have to
always keep this in mind
because i never had style or coolness so
i didn't actually have to give it up
it's a very it was a very easy
transition as you know i was born in a
flannel with a beard so
um i have been essentially a very uncool
dad my whole life
and so for someone who had some style
and coolness it's a more difficult
transition and that's you know that's
that's in my wife's defense a little bit
and the other thing is that she has she
has um
clung successfully
in parenthood to many different things
that that naysayers including myself
told her she'd have to give up for
example white couches she still buys
white furniture
okay
we have expensive white couches in our
family room
and somehow they're not totally
destroyed even with four kids
so
give her credit for that uh let's see
evan says matt on the subject of dying
with dignity i'm curious to hear your
take on something my dad's brother died
of dementia unable to even
recognize his own children my dad's dad
is a strong man and he has taken his age
an inevitable decline with grace but he
refuses to go out the way his brother
did he has signed a living will asking
to have the plug pulled if he's ever
lying in bed as an invalid who can't
recognize his own family i'm hoping it
never comes to that but if it does i've
told him i respect his wishes and pull
the plug do you think that i'm out of
line telling him that it's an honest
question i really do appreciate your
point of view on these matters well
there's a difference between a suicide
right and
removing life support or you know
pulling the plug
so called
um and i as for the latter i think the
ethics of it really depend on the
circumstances so if somebody is old and
dying
[Music]
and entirely dependent on machines
to survive
then no i don't think that they have a
moral responsibility to stay on the
machines and prolong their lives for as
long as humanly possible but when you
get to the point the only thing is
keeping you alive are all these machines
and you've lived a long life and uh
and you say you know i'm this is my time
and and
i'm willing to go
when god decides and and i'm going to
leave it up to to that and i'm not going
to
use the machines i think that's um
a perfectly ethically defensible
choice i mean at a certain point you
have to
accept the inevitable
um
and at a certain point even perhaps the
responsibility goes the other way like
you don't have the responsibility to
prolong your life for as long as you
possibly can and there might become a
time where ethically irresponsibility
falls on accepting the inevitable
um but it's a difficult question and
like i said the the circumstances
uh really really determinate
okay
and finally megan says are you gonna do
anything special for your 1000th episode
on friday it's a big milestone for the
show and the spg congratulations in
advance advance actually since you
mention it our 1000th episode will be
monday it will not be tomorrow tomorrow
we'll have some special content for you
that we're putting together that i'm
excited about
uh so we're gonna have that but it won't
be an official episode we are saving the
1000th episode for monday because we
want it to coincide
with something else that we're working
on that's almost finished but not yet
and uh
that's the most i can say about
is it uh ironic to make an ad for an
ad-free viewing experience
maybe that's not really irony it's like
the atlantis more set definition of
irony but anyway that's exactly the type
of experience you're going to get that
is the ad free experience when you
subscribe to daily wire plus this is our
growing hub for all things daily wire
where you'll find shows and podcasts
like this one movies bonus content and
coming soon kids content as well daily
wire plus is everything you love about
the daily wire plus so much more and
minus the ads as well go to
dailywireplus.com to become a member
today and get 35 percent off of your
membership now that's
dailywireplus.com now let's get to our
daily cancellation
[Music]
today we return to the subject of racism
and parade mascots
it is not a subject that i would choose
to dwell on but this is a a show that
analyzes and discusses culture and this
is what our culture cares about so to
briefly review a few weeks ago somebody
in a sesame street costume had a parade
and sesame place in philadelphia made
the mistake of walking past a black
child without stopping to greet her
specifically of course mascots walk by
many children all the time without
greeting them for reasons that are
obvious but this one innocuous event was
caught on film conveniently clipped to
remove all context and nationwide
outrage ensued charges of racism were
made apologies were issued soon
afterwards another family filed a class
action lawsuit on behalf of all black
families that have been victims of
similar mascot-related hate crimes but
the completely made-up problem of racist
mascots extends beyond sesame street
apparently the costumed rodents at chuck
e cheese are also racist
no telling if the actual rodents that
also frequent chuck e cheese are racist
as well but we can only take one problem
at a time this week another video went
viral of a black child being horribly
traumatized
by the minor disappointment of not
receiving a high five from a costumed
character
the mother of the victim tweeted the
shocking footage let's watch it
thank you thank you it's great to be
here with you to celebrate these amazing
birthday stars now for those of you who
don't know when you celebrate your
birthday at chuck e cheese's you are the
star of the show in fact
horrific
now she captioned this uh she captured
this with this please retweet on july
30th at chuck e cheese in wayne new
jersey my two-year-old was racially
discriminated against as you can see he
gives all the white kids high fives and
purposely ignored my black baby when
confronted he ignored me as well the
manager angie velasquez made excuses for
him
ah yes that notorious white supremacist
angie velasquez of new jersey
that's a clan name if ever i've heard
one
now she says that uh the manager made
excuses i can't imagine what those
excuses might be other than the fact
that all the kids who received high
fives were standing on a stage eye level
with the mascot the child who was
snubbed was standing three feet below
them given that your line of sight is
almost non-existent in those sweltering
death trap costumes the most logical
explanation is that the kids on the
stage were within his limited vision and
the child below the stage was not
so that's a logical explanation but it's
not a lucrative explanation
if you're looking to cash in as this
mother clearly is then the only
explanation you'll possibly entertain is
that the person in the mouse costume who
you don't know and who may be black
themselves for all you know
is racist
not only that but for whatever reason
the costumed character gig attracts
racist there is a conspiracy among
mascots nationwide to traumatize black
children
this is what you allege when your demand
for racism far far outstrips the supply
now for the record chuck e cheese was of
course prepared to fold at a moment's
notice they didn't put up any fight at
all i mean none
chucky cheese corporate released a
statement expressing that they were
deeply saddened by this event quote
as home to millions of families and kids
every year that celebrates the big and
small milestones including fun
our goal is to create an inclusive
experience for children and parents of
all ages races ethnicities religious
backgrounds and learning differences
our mission is to provide a fun and safe
place where a kid can be a kid and all
cast members are trained to ensure that
we live up to this promise
now you notice how on the left
uh where they pretend to champion the
poor and the working class they have no
problem at all with giant corporations
making scapegoats out of their minimum
wage employees throwing them throwing
them to the wolves
and branding them with the letter r for
racist
you know they have no problem with that
because because of course these people
don't give the slightest damn about the
working class or the poor or anybody
else
in fact the more powerless somebody is
the better because the easier it is to
get them to dance to your tune the
leftist outrage mob thrives on
manipulation and intimidation it is
their fetish
they feel orgasmic delight at the site
of some poor sap bowing before them this
was made all the more apparent yesterday
when another video went viral
this one from a parade at disney world
but the mascot these are toy story
characters this time around
they didn't make the same mistake so in
this video woody
spots a black girl in the crowd
and frantically waves for the other toy
story character to come over so that she
can greet the child let's let's watch
that happening
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
okay so i actually i don't know if that
music was actually playing at the parade
for kids i wouldn't be surprised if it
was i don't think it was i think that
was just put in in post
um so you see there the person in the
cowgirl costume i don't know what what's
the name of that character i don't know
um
what was it say it again jesse okay
jesse in the cowgirl there um almost
walked by the black child without
noticing her which would have been as
we've seen a national tragedy and a
catastroph catastrophe of historic
proportions fortunately though through
woody's diligent efforts she noticed at
the last second and sprinted over to uh
give the young black girl the biggest
and most specialist greeting
out of all the other kids at the parade
never mind that she didn't hug the other
black kids right next to that girl
i guess she's going to get a pass in
this case until the parents of those
kids decide to sue for a 100 million
dollars of course
now the media has been
reporting on that little video there
like it's a heart-warming sort of human
interest story
but it's actually quite sad and pathetic
and terrifying
the minimum wage lackey in the costume
knows that they'll be smeared nationally
as a racist probably fired
and may be sued if they don't specially
acknowledge every black child or at
least every black child with a litigious
parent holding a camera
the hug was a hug given by someone who
knows that they're going to be
arbitrarily attacked libeled and
destroyed if they commit an entirely
innocuous and innocent oversight
this is somebody frantically trying to
avoid a fate
that shouldn't be anywhere within the
ballpark of possibilities in the first
place there should be zero risk that a
kid in a costume at a parade will end up
in the headlines for accidentally
walking past a black child in the crowd
there should be no risk of that
this is now a real risk in our depraved
idiot-infested culture
now the situation is not sustainable i
mean ultimately
and this will happen within the next few
months probably if not weeks companies
like disney and sesame street and chuck
e cheese will instate policies
forbidding mascots from greeting anybody
at all
allowing them to do greetings is now a
liability because if any video surfaces
of any mascot failing to greet any black
child even if that same mascot greeted
50 black children before it becomes a pr
scandal and probably a lawsuit
companies will judge it simply not worth
the risk and they're going to do away
with what was once totally normal and
seemingly risk-free
the outrage mob destroys then yet
another small little thing that once
brought joy to children but now must be
taken away because the parasites got a
hold of it
and the most important thing we can
learn from this and take note of
is again
just how much joy
these leeches take in all of this
you know the the their uh the leftist
mob they were passing around that video
for the disney world video yesterday
laughing hysterically about it they
think it's the greatest thing in the
world
the very people who pretended to be
upset at sesame street and chuck e
cheese are laughing
because they can see that their charade
has its desired effects
because they love nothing in this world
more than seeing people jump through the
hoops that they have set up
and that's all the more reason
to never give these frauds what they
want defy them at every opportunity
laugh in their faces
never apologize
before they have a chance to say it to
you
you must always say to them
you are
cancelled and we'll leave it there for
today
um that'll do it for this week we have
again uh something special for you
tomorrow and then we'll be back with uh
with a regular show on monday
and it'll be our 1000th episode so i'll
see you then godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavel dowsky
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by jeff tomlin our
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is done by cherokee heart the
matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022